una defensora pionera de la igualdad de
género e icono cultural la jueza de la
corte suprema de eeuu
ruth báder ginsburg puso una larga
carrera legal impulsada por sus propias
luchas como mujer en la profesión
dominada por hombres en la facultad de
derecho de harvard fue una de las nueve
mujeres de una clase de 500 estudiantes
y después de graduarse de columbia como
la mejor de su año todavía se enfrentó a
dificultades para encontrar trabajo ya
que los jueces federales no querían
contratar mujeres en 1972
ginsburg con fundó el proyecto de
derechos de la mujer en la unión
estadounidense de libertades civiles
para 1974 el organismo había participado
en más de 300 demandas por
discriminación de género
ginsburg se ganó una reputación con su
trabajo lento pero constante
favoreciendo las batallas ganables por
encima de los casos llamativos
mientras sentaba gradualmente las bases
legales para lograr la igualdad de
género en 1994 fue nominada a la corte
suprema por bill clinton convirtiéndola
en la segunda mujer en servir en el
máximo órgano judicial de eeuu allí
continúe defendiendo los derechos de las
mujeres con sentencias sobre temas
controversiales como el aborto y fue
reconocida por ser una gran disidente
cuando la gente le preguntaba cuántos de
los nueve escaños del tribunal debían
ocupar mujeres ella siempre daba la
misma respuesta
wen dice cuando crees que habrá
suficiente
es obvio cuando haya 9
su pequeña estatura combinada con su
rechazo a dejarse intimidar la hizo
ascender al estatus de ícono de la
cultura pop lo que le valió el apodo de
la notoria vejez por sus iniciales la
nominación de donald trump de dos jueces
de la corte suprema dejó a ginsburg como
uno de los cuatro progresistas cruciales
para mantener el equilibrio en la corte
de tendencia conservadora su
fallecimiento podría reforzar dicha
mayoría en la corte suprema donde hasta
ahora los progresistas eran minoría